hello there sweet Internet I'm gab I'm
down we're the slow mo guys dan what's
this bowl about a Chinese sprouting ball
its sole purpose is to make water jump
out everywhere that's it a very
purpose-built bowl yeah that's it we saw
a gif of this online where what was
leaping out and we thought that looked
fantastic in slow motion talked about
getting it for the show and Dan was like
I like the idea of this bowl so much I'm
gonna buy it with my own money yeah I'm
taking at home much you own this bowl
yes mine this is your bowl yeah so what
you gonna do with it when it's when
we're done here put potpourri in it or
something
I guess so oh just let people rub it
occasionally I'm gonna come in hopefully
this video resonates well with the
audience sounds good to me I can't
believe it that was the stretch pretty
cool yeah can you get it to resonate in
different spots or is it always from
those before call these fish from these
four corners but you can get it to do
different patterns like how the waves go
there like that so if you do it from
this side only does it yeah you see the
little pansy does there oh my hands are
in the shadow
makes like a really fine pattern we'll
get both that's really annoying it's
stuff Oh CY always to take it home like
an annoyed people okay intergalactic
planetary okay try one and let me know
when it's good okay it takes a minute to
build up so yeah yeah this channel is
gonna give you the oddest set of skills
[Music]
no weird like from the bowl pushes out
just a weird effect then it starts
rising up from there
really cool you can see the whole thing
Jocelyn
Wow that's cool the whole ball was going
yeah Wow thank you I couldn't see any of
that movement in real life right I guess
I was distracted by the wall but the
whole ball is like in real time it takes
ages to get it going but then when it's
good it just goes crazy whoa look at the
bowl Wibbly it's like a giant speaker
yeah I like how perfectly it's been
designed yeah they knew what they were
doing my honesty that's gonna fly it so
them just get lon yeah I'll just he sure
there's something like see yeah yeah
that's the kind of stuff you can just
look how over there you know that's
wicked my screensaver
Wow yeah you can see where the movement
of the war starts I didn't have all the
way up in the handle it's like your hand
is moving smoothly but the handle is
gripping and letting go and working the
lingo and causing the ball to move that
way because it's such a high frequency
yeah
do any way you would be able to see is
the slow motion obviously but I just
thought it was just like a single
squeaking sound you never be able to see
it
well I think I could watch slo-mo
globules collide all day luckily this is
an absolute glob Factory very good it is
indeed a glob factory yeah it's also
quite scientifically interesting with
the way the gloves come up with the bowl
resonating yeah the frequency the barn
and the way that I guess the the waves
come from your hands at these different
points caused it to come up in four
different locations in a round Bowl it's
like one of those tables you get when
you take the bow to it in the mix the
patterns in the sand it's just like that
yeah remember the tuning fork video we
did where we showed the gloves coming up
from either side of that yeah this is
like that on steroids it's just really
happy with your purchase I think you're
jealous you want I would want one yeah I
probably want to be automatic though
yeah of course yeah sort of like
voice-activated like Alexa make the
Chinese ball make the gloves and then
it's mug hopefully you enjoyed that
video feel free to follow us on Twitter
that's the hour distraction we have a
channel it's this one will serve a
second channel for behind the scenes and
we will see you in the next video I'm a
strong enough I bet that's annoying oh
yeah annoy the neighbors of this